[Music]
the emergence of organic life from what
preceded it is as dramatic a miracle as
anyone could imagine the emergence of
language from mute best reality which is
only a hundred thousand years in the
past is as dramatic a miracle
as anyone could imagine the emergence of
a planet instantaneously unified by
electricity and media is and this is
only 50 60 years in our past it's still
going on is as dramatic a miracle as
anyone could imagine
it's absolutely irrational to not be
filled with the fire of concern and hope
you just have to overcome to the
leveling that we inherit from these
empty existential scientific ideas and
when we do that and lift our eyes to the
real living spiritually empowered
reality that exists in nature in society
in our lover in ourselves then you see
that the Peacocks tail the powder Pavone
mace is a transcendental object at the
end of time an enormous unspeakable
something that that penance
across the historical landscape the
past's an enormous shadow that leeches
clear back to the earliest moments of
the universe that we have always been in
the grip of that iridescent strange
attractor it has propelled our poetry
our art our best moments have always
been when the tiny spark of that
alchemical completion burned for a
moment in our mind in our life in our
perception and leave occupy a special
position in regard to this means
thousands of generations of human beings
have come and gone and could only
glimpse this in the ecstasy of eroticism
and psychedelic empowerment and ritual
magic but we are the last people beyond
us lies the mystery if we have but the
courage to move forward into that abyss
to believe that nature will reward the
dreamer it cannot wander much longer all
of the preconditions have been met and
the Peacocks tail grows daily whiter and
more radiant and more brilliant as we
sense now breaking into our dreams
breaking into our
and why's the presence of this attractor
it has always given a people meaning
that we are the privileged inheritors of
that meaning and we have been the
privilege of putting it all together in
one piece and standing ready at the end
of history to go into the mystery and be
completed
you
you